hi how's it going unemployed a hurry
it's going surprise birthday today and
I'm running late I'm supposed to be here
at 6:30 and I don't have everything
today wine and champagne and they also
got gummy bears because when I bought
this Rose a just showed up as an extra
to add on and I'm not sure why but I
said okay we've also got some cupcakes
and a pie and I don't know what they
look like I mean could you have like
shoved them in there a little bit more
how many tape my only option for tape
all right you want we're just not going
to open the other one we're just going
to hope that it doesn't look like crap
I'll keep the FAMAS on gift card in it
comes in like a little Amazon cardboard
box this is incredible this is cute
right how is this gonna okay well
interesting this is what I call art I
missed you so much Mady while I was in
New York did you miss mommy a lot of you
guys have been saying Justine where are
your vlogs I miss your vlogs I haven't
been posting daily vlogs because I'd
rather post longer better vlogs and a
bunch of crappy vlogs so they're a
little bit more sporadic so I hope you
guys understand granda not all of my
videos can be crazy cinematic short
films but I will try my best to make
them as cool and fun as possible without
losing my mind I'm spending so much time
editing oh my gosh I've got a lot of
stuff
[Music]
hi how are you here this is look so
often so Joey's Indonesia is very very
soon
[Music]
[Applause]
creepy always wanted for puppies on
watching for our puppy hey I love me I'm
like there's no way look at me I'm just
sitting here eating you're recording you
just realizing what were you talking
earlier I don't think we've seen each
other since we shot it was like a
college humor
yeah yeah yeah it's actually really good
lots of gun violence really cool stuff
it actually turned out very well
imagine our role got in jail you were
there playing youtuber Hunger Games I
remember that
did you remember like so now like their
physical therapy first and you feel beat
yeah not my rotator I like the old
shoulder out of wood oh my god just
because I'm a young person wait did I
should I end up killing you I think I
hit her in the head she fell I thought I
killed you
on the train like I shot you but you had
that bulletproof vest on so you came
back and you got me when I was least
expecting it I was trying to happen
Wooster face but you haven't managed oh
and then you guys have you guys have
showdown I mean I don't even have an
interesting story you just killed me and
it was really my partner is great it
turned out very well fun
Oh
[Music]
hey daddy night do you feel like mommy
okay hi Ann Oh how's it going pretty
good
I'm blogging today Oh Rover right now we
are heading to go to brunch I'm so
excited this is like my favorite brunch
spot and we're meeting Sarah and John
and I believe that John might be
bringing some electric skateboard oh I
have an extra helmet if you want one
upstairs
nothing can helmet Oh No resupply yeah
maybe just grab a roll of something look
guys what has happened oh no oh that cup
was stuck in the cup holder but I don't
know why it bubbled up into like a
disgusting I don't even know what you
think where's it going somewhere like
this actually might have ruined my car
there's a really good chin you know if
we don't blog it's not happening really
oh this is disgusting hey guys are
related why
how'd you screw my cart are you building
what now yeah oh my gosh Bravo
having never driven in a while I forget
now for which radio functions and once
helps I've stationed select stations
radio info HD radio traffic information
always always no function oh my gosh
always control of what lies to go this
in the mineral Hey look who's here
this is great this is like my favorite
place you guys have seen us coming
before the Wilshire and you just kind of
some complimentary cinnamon rolls and
I'm freaking out freaking it off I have
my birthday parties you guys remember
that the centerpiece of the party is the
switch enjoy your swing oh yes which I
played with cookies these are so awesome
yeah I remember cuz these cinnamon rolls
got eaten out and had one bite but
Jennifer was all the frosting on my
sweater it smelled frosting all day
because it's right here I remember that
[Music]
oh boy yeah okay but how do you stop is
the question I put my helmet on so I'll
just come back what happened what is
guys did you guys go to the safety
product or soft elbow pad yep for elbow
pad right see the problem is not for
kids
well neither kids don't have upset on me
you lie you will if you swallow that me
doctor special they're so tight like
they're literally for ten-year-old to
like real do see that look at that
oh wait hey there bro shot all right you
guys your ever when I try skateboarding
before
[Music]
okay there was that time and then
there's this time I never even ended up
posting that video Jordan and I went to
a skate park once and Jordan is actually
a really great skateboarder
[Music]
I on the other hand I'm not tricky stop
Oh God okay but I tried and he tried to
teach me where'd you want to go lift up
today I'm all geared up and we're with
Sarah and John and Ed's over there we're
going to trying out some Electric
skateboards and I've been so intrigued
because you see everybody boosting
around the cities in their booster
boards and it looks incredibly
terrifying so today we're going to try
them out let's see what it's all about
that Ron got him such a lyricist let's
talk about this board though very very
PA
hey well how'd it go
danger
[Music]
I am so proud of you did you guys see
like did I just see her land I Tony Hawk
call me maybe
oh hey when you movin to LA oh don't
tell me Justine there I just found
apartment in New York so clearly I'm
just gonna I'm just tease it I'm so
excited I'm so excited that you found a
place though yeah it's good it's good to
visit LA that's my favorite okay you
know yep you know here when your lease
is up girls
[Music]